[Music]
you look fantastic you look beautiful as
always
yeah thank you for being here look this
dress is fantastic I've got an antenna
in it you think they'd come up with a
more elegant way to put a microphone on
what your it just weird this beautiful
dress then you have a 1940's radio
strapped to your low back you grounded
so much to talk about we just watched a
fight scene one of a thousand great
moments from this movie I got to see it
the other night and the fighting in this
movie it's a terrific movie the special
effects are great but your fighting is
fantastic thank you very much I mean
there we saw you fighting Colin Farrow
you have a lot of fight scenes with
Jessica Biel and you two are really
going at it really fighting each other
and I have to say it's a lot of fun to
watch okay I know that sounds pervy and
I meant it too I meant it to be perfect
yeah I always worried that people are
gonna be disappointed that we're not in
you know both full of jelly as I feel
people are making this this fight I'm
just being a creep but the fighting is
very good and it's also it's very
intense it really does look like you're
you're you're fighting a losing you're
hurting each other well we we were very
polite about it though because I've
never fought with another girl before
and you know there's a lot of oh my god
I'm so sorry that was my fault and did I
touch your ears and you know that kind
of things right right yeah it's
different
so they edit that out thankfully they
did yes maybe it'll be on the DVD and
and and there's a scene where you're
choking Colin Farrell using your legs
and it was just like they've it's well I
sort of fly at him with my actually not
my legs my legs are open I kind of fly
it
I got all confused that knowledge well
it was like it was the second day and it
was you know that was awkward enough to
be honest with you but actually I was
obviously I was on a wire and and they
dragged me across the floor and and and
my my shoes made this awful kind of
fatty noise flying towards him and I
could see this kind of look of horror on
Colin's face like oh my god you'll parry
European and free you're powering
yourself towards him thank you for
passing now your your husband Len
Weitzman's the director and he wanted
you to be in this film and you almost
didn't do it I almost wasn't available
yeah I mean I was doing another movie
and the dates weren't looking like they
were going to line up so he he was very
bummed about that and then started kind
of auditioning other people and then he
said but I still really want you in the
movie and you know there's a part of
this of this three-breasted prostitute
would you mind doing that you can't see
that quickly
no there's a three-breasted it's a you
know sort of alien were there's a
three-breasted prostitute in the movie
he wanted you to play that part well
yeah he was sad that wasn't in the movie
so he said well why did it's only one
day you know maybe you could do that and
I thought okay I mean I've only got the
to only one and a heart one of them is
kind of squinting a bit anyway and I've
had a baby sorry to - everything but
at all anyway I didn't end up doing and
I'm glad because she's got I think a bit
more attention than both Jessica and I
put together there's a lot of attention
it's a very quick scene where you just
see this it's obviously clearly a
prosthetic device
yeah I've ruined it they didn't go out
and find a three breast it's a
prosthetic device that clearly your
husband wanted you to have you can play
it for a day and that's exactly what he
was we all